this is Norwich but it could be any town
or city in Britain at the weekend the
trouble that so often follows an
alcohol-fueled night out means more
police are needed to keep a lid on any
aggro but soon it seems the bars who
sold the booze could be made to help
pick up the bill in the form of a late
night levy Toby Middleton is operations
director for six bars and two clubs he
isn't impressed they're going to turn
around and tell me that I'm going to
have to pay four and a half thousand
pound her venue or / venue of what I own
around here yeah and give me a lot of it
news that's going to be Shane very very
very quickly and then what you're going
to do is you're going to kill your night
time economy you wait up the night so no
economy there are more people unemployed
yeah you've just lost a hell of a lot of
money it's all part of the police reform
and social responsibility bill licensing
authorities will be able to charge from
300 to nearly four and a half thousand
pounds depending on the premises and the
Liberal Democrats have their own ideas
too they're considering other ways for
councils to raise additional taxes like
a surcharge on every drink paid for by
the customer would offset not just
policing but also health costs if a bit
more money or drinks out so people
aren't going to come out this with
whites only pubs and bars
you just think it's like Oh freebie I'll
get in a scrap for that yeah you don't
realize how much money is costing
taxpayers and all am so you think a good
idea honestly I do yeah if it means that
there's more protection on the streets
and I pay twenty one percent of all
violent crime happens in or around pubs
bars and clubs the annual cost to
taxpayers of alcohol related crime and
disorder is estimated to be as high as
13 billion pounds and the NHS bill alone
is put at 2.7 billion a year it's all
about social responsibility the idea
being that if it's the alcohol you're
buying or selling that's resulting in
the need for more police then maybe it's
only fair you help foot the bill what
levies and surcharges don't do is deal
with the heavy drinking that's causing
the trouble in the first place and that
according to alcohol concern is the
problem the Levien's links industry
won't actually address the root cause it
won't stop people necessarily from
drinking too much alcohol way to stop
people from drinking too much alcohol or
to deter them from taking too much
alcohol is to raise the price of alcohol
in those establishments the late night
levy is expected to come in later this
year and may do nothing to beat
Britain's booze culture but it will at
least help clean up the mess Emma
virtually Sky News Norwich